leiter des kondoms die abscheidung etwas
geht auch jetzt willkommen zu einem
kleinen video intro-video wir hatten ja
schon angesprochen vor irgendwann haben
ein video gemacht haben wir gesagt ja
wenn ihr bock habt dass wir zusammen
kanal machen schreibt sie die kommentare
oder last noch nach oben oder so und
jetzt haben wir uns gedacht mach mach es
einfach mal
wir haben dann jetzt einen channel
aufgemacht der heißt not really vaters
und den link findet ihr einmal in der
video beschreibung also wäre halb
ziemlich heiß wenn ihr drauf gehen
würdet abonnieren würde welche bock
gehabt und dann schauen wir mal wie
viele von den abonnenten die ich hier so
rüberkommt und ja ganz einfach aus dem
grund haben wir den channel gemacht zu
zweites lustiger videos zu drehen ich
habe bock sowas auf wir machen das so
ich mache hier meinen hauptkanal
natürlich als hauptkanal weiter und dann
drehen wir ab und zu noch ein video das
kannst du dann schneiden habe ich keine
zeit zu unter service zu tun
deswegen schlägt das auf jeden fall ab
da kommen halt auch so ein bisschen
andere art von videos hat auf jeden fall
also hier ab und zu pellets oder so oder
auch so ich weiß nicht zu zeitig ist man
viel kreativer da kommen auf jeden fall
gute sachen also dem check das auch
hinten ab und ist auch du noch irgendwas
dazu idol passiert dann kann das müssen
wir auf jeden fall ja gut
ansonsten würde ich sagen das war es
auch schon mit diesem kurzen video eine
sache noch hier ich habe mir dieses
snapshot geholt und wenn ihr bock gehabt
das ist so da kann jetzt jeder meine
story sehen deswegen auch mein name ist
in der video beschreibung könnt ihr
vielleicht wenn ihr bock habt folgt
meter oder edit mich da ich weiß nicht
wie es nennen soll auf jeden fall
schuldig weil da kann man jede scheiße
post sondern muss man nicht immer super
arbeiten filter auf lara ist schon
deswegen so viel dazu und haut rein wir
sehen uns nächste woche